this program is brought to you in living
color on NBC the opening and some audio
portions were pre-recorded tonight live
the 46th annual Academy Award
presentation
this is the Music Center in Los Angeles
California where these crowds have been
gathering since dawn today and where the
excitement has been building up to this
climactic moment the arrival of
Hollywood's most glamorous stars for the
night ceremony
there's Paul Newman with lovely wife
Joanne Woodward Vince Carney denominated
for bang the drum slowly Diana Ross
composer Burt Bacharach and lovely wife
Angie Dickinson nominee Paul McCartney
and wife Linda there's Jack Lemmon Best
Actor nominee for save the tiger rugged
Charles Bronson with Jill Ireland
talented Walter Matthau the infinity of
glamour Raquel Welch venerable Groucho
Marx who will be honored on tonight's
show Burt Reynolds one of tonight's
hosts with Dinah Shore Joe Dre Oscar
winner last year for cabaret the
original trenchcoat
Peter posh Billy Friedkin a nominee for
the Exorcist Marcel Marceau perhaps the
world's greatest time ladies and
gentlemen
Liza Minnelli
differently songs about my ragtime
cowboy
Cole Porter wrote a tune called Tom Dick
or Harry
then there was or Johnny or m1 and Sam
to make the pants too long and Jim you
remember that clap hands here comes
charlie and uh oh and Ben the rat but
there's a name that no-one no one's ever
used
no no to Smith yet has dared to try it
this era has me totally confuse
but tonight my friend
I intend to rectify
everybody Oh
scoot yeah everybody loves you
skirt believe everybody don't you
society wants to get the celebrated
statuette me bones
shivering knees and may I have the
envelope please
and then the famous piece of his godson
and the winner is inches in hunt
whatever happens is that a mind I wanna
get you're going home with us
I'm 1971 the nominees for Best
Performance by an actress in a starring
role are geneviève Bujold a Jane Fonda
for they shoot horses don't they
gene Simmons for happy ending Liza
Minnelli for the sterile cuckoo and
Maggie Smith for the prime of Miss Jean
Brodie well I don't have to fit I've got
a good feeling about it I mean actually
I know that the thing is just not to
think about it and I refuse to think
about it I will not I can't stop
thinking about it
I mean first of all man this terrific
manager she does divine work and I went
to her and she told me that she'd never
been wrong once ever and she said that
you could actually see me just going
right on up there's just top in the box
so I mean I don't know where to put it
my house I can set it up on them and
your winner is simple but I can build
Maggie Smith for the prime of Miss Jean
Brodie
some years of waffle depressing as can
be and some years on 1973 the truly
talented ladies nominated for Best
Performance by an actress are Liza
Minnelli in cabaret Diana Ross and Lady
Sings the Blues Maggie Smith and
traveled with my aunt Cicely Tyson and
sounder leave woman in the immigrants
the real point is what am I doing here
I mean I'm going to lose I'm so sad well
I've got a dress it's yellow and it's a
gala
I mean it's just it's just um and
they're gonna show my picture I'm you
standing have to smile absolute where's
my head and she said not you this your
big girl and she's ten years
and the winner is liza minnelli for
cabaret
Oh
every fire rose to get shot ramya hug
hold tight
and who's holding hands with Oscar
dragon around Alaska going home with us
MA
that's the one
the president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences and an
oscar-winning producer himself mr.
Walton
Thank You Liza and good evening ladies
and gentlemen its traditional at these
ceremonies for the president to welcome
you on behalf of the Academy and I do so
tonight with great pleasure I think it's
also traditional for president of the
Academy to be asked repeatedly just what
it is that the Academy does besides give
awards I like to answer this question by
simply saying but like all academies it
seeks primarily
to encourage excellence undoubtedly the
best-known way in which it does this is
by bestowing its world-renowned Oscar
but the Academy also encourages
excellence in many other ways it
annually presents awards to five
outstanding films made by cinema
students it supports an internship
program which subsidizes young
filmmakers while affording them the
opportunity of observing outstanding
directors it maintains the best and most
complete library of Motion Picture
material in the world it sponsors
various screenings retrospectives and
publications it Awards special grants
and scholarships and conducts an artisan
residence program and Veyron various
college campuses and so as you can see
the Academy is more than just Oscar
night it's a continuing effort to
promote the spirit and influence of
Oscar the incentive for excellence in
motion pictures throughout the ranks of
all filmmakers tonight we should like to
pause for a moment and remember someone
whose devotion to the pursuit of
excellence and motion pictures is
legendary
as a producer myself I take particular
pride in dedicating this evening
ceremonies to the memory of that pioneer
and master producer so many great films
such as pride of the Yankees dead end
the little foxes dies and dolls and of
course watering Heights
this evening is for a gentleman who
truly gave of himself and in so doing
gave us some of the best years of our
lives Samuel Goldwyn
thank you now ladies and gentlemen I
would like to introduce our first host
of the evening mr. Burt Reynolds
uh thank you I know the Oscars are
important but I have something more
important I have a phone message here or
miss st. John from a mr. Kissinger in
Acapulco it says that I'll be here for
seven more days so if you call your name
is Al I want to welcome you to the 46
Annual Academy Awards was a great shock
to be picked as one of the hosts for the
Oscars not to me but to the Academy I
look out there tonight I see a room
packed with every star in Hollywood and
I can't help thinking if this building
should cave in which I think it's doing
if this building should cave in the
hottest star in Hollywood tomorrow would
be Keith Purcell
it's an exciting night no Hollywood and
I can't help but feel the tension here
not yours mine I don't care about yours
and I want to tell you something I was
thinking about coming over here you got
to recognize one thing right now in New
York Beverly Hills Bel Air all over the
country they're cocktail parties filled
with people saying nasty Kaddi snide
remarks so they're putting this down
about the way we're dressed so unfunny
we are how unsophisticated we are and
you know where that comes from
they haven't been nominated they haven't
been invited or they're just too chic to
be here so to all you people out there
from all of us here
that's about as sophisticated and
dignified as I'm gonna get folks you
want sophistication go to lunch with
david niven it's child intestine here
yet
he is here why uh some some great movies
of anomaly this year and one of the
favorites is the sting starring that
great twosome Paul Newman and Robert
Redford the greatest romantic team since
Bogart and Bacall
well not quite as romantic but prettier
I I love the title this thing it reminds
me of an old army training film
a lot of people have accused me of being
jealous of Robert Redford just because
he has three gigantic pictures coming
out and he's the hottest actor in town
but I asked you Bob up there on that
mountaintop so perfect I asked you Bob
and I'm gonna speak slowly so you can
understand me if you're so perfect Bobby
why haven't you done Hollywood Squares
of course Bob won't be here tonight and
he's in pretty good company George see
Scott won't be here Marlon Brando won't
be here there are a lot of people who
won't show up to get what's coming to
them speaking to Richard Nixon we're
gonna talk about the
I'm going to talk about the voting
procedures and here to explain how
everything is voted on and why I'm not
up for anything again is that incredibly
incredibly talented star of the Paper
Chase mr. Timothy bottoms
Thank You Berg good evening okay as in
the past this is the time in the show
where the voting procedures are
explained in great depth hopefully to
the satisfaction of everyone it's really
very simple and tonight I'm going to try
and translate them once and for all all
eligible Academy members are asked to
vote for nominations for Best Picture of
the year the other nominations are made
by the members of the various branches
of the Academy specialists in their
fields costume designers nominate
costume designers film editors film
editors directors nominate directors
writers writers and of course actors
nominate other actors if at this point
they're not familiar with the potential
nominations they can view them at
special screening set up by the Academy
finally after the nominations are
announced all members have the
opportunity to vote for all awards merit
transmitting their secret ballots
directly to the Academy's independent
accountants Price Waterhouse & Company
where they are tabulated in secrecy when
the day of truth arrives representatives
of the firm deliver the final outcome in
sealed envelopes to this theater where
they are handed over to their
representative to the presenters in this
same sealed envelope everybody says
please for and this is the gentlemen in
final possession of them mister Robert
Ford
this is the 46th year these voting
procedures have been explained and I
feel safe and saying that 46 years from
now you'll still be hearing them
I hope so thank you very much
I think Timothy deserves a another round
of applause for having to read that the
same people that had Timothy do that
want him tomorrow to go on The Today
Show and explain the economy
I know a lot of people are sitting here
tonight a little uptight maybe feeling a
little uncomfortable wasn't easy getting
your in carpools
before we get to the first award they've
asked me to talk to you about your Thank
You speeches every year they do this and
they say keep him short
everybody makes them long as a matter of
fact two years ago there was a speech
done by Cloris Leachman that is going to
be released as a 90-minute special so in
case you're planning a real surprise for
us forget it it's been done we've dug
into the archives looked at over 40
years of Oskar shows even back before
television and we've chosen these
highlights acceptors who who have graced
the stage with that certain poise in a
plum never losing their dignity during
the great emotional moment I mean when
it comes to accepting an Oscar you've
got some pretty strong acts to follow
John Addison for Tom Jones
oh I am I am i they gave me the wrong
envelope way to the n-double-a-cp hears
about this is the Oscar one of the roles
are the motion picture roles what's that
sweetie
in unis I know how excited miss Harris
will be ladies and gentlemen I'm the
world's greatest Gatecrasher and I just
came here to present Bob Hope with his
1938 trophy
they are Bob Denver who needs
Pricewaterhouse
all we needs a doorman thank you very
much I wish I could take the name home
with me instead of his liver I may have
the baby right in here don't let anybody
tell you this isn't a terrific thrill I
can't tell you how encouraging a thing
like this is on I should say if you're
very special thank you oh he's so
beautiful
whoa eat that birdie hello gorgeous
hello dad
the winner is George the sky thank you
double dutch but my delight as such I be
for me
you
you
thank you very much
this year we decided to reinstate
something we haven't had for a few years
the guardians of Oscar so instead of the
statues being brought up each time by a
couple of unknown gentlemen and rented
tuxedos we've got two very talented and
attractive ladies to do it this year
wasn't my idea but I'm only a host and
I'm not going to fight it ladies and
gentlemen
Oscars Guardians the star of coffee miss
Pam Grier and a young lady who starred
the motion picture judge Roy Bean Miss
Victoria Principal
hello hello Victoria ah now for the
reason we're all here this year's awards
would you like to take it don't take
this one to present the first award for
Best Short subject is a young man who
last year brought his magnetic presents
to a couple of outstanding dramatic
betrayals and the young lady whose
motion picture debut has resulted in an
Oscar nomination and has made her one of
the most talked-about short subjects of
the year mr. Billy Dee Williams and Miss
Linda Blair
I know a lot of people like to ask you I
get the opportunity to do it how did you
ever see yourself in Exorcist
well I don't like standing in lines you
gotta be kidding
I guess the devil made me say it
nominees for the best achievement and
animated short subjects are Frank film
Frank Morris producer The Legend of John
Henry Nick the susto David Adams
producers Politan Ella Manuel lazatti
Giulio Giannini producers may we have
the envelope please
and the winner is
Frank film Frank Morris
Andy Warhol says that in the future
everyone will be famous for 15 minutes
right now we'll settle for nine minutes
called Frank film Tony Schwartz Karolina
all fours
Yale school Avadh Harvard's carpenter
Center for the visual arts and I thank
you very much
in live short subjects the nominees are
the Bolero Alan Miller and William for
tech producers clock maker Richard Gere
producer live times nine pen Densham and
John Watson producers the envelope
please thank you and the winner is the
Bolero Alan Miller and William first day
a lot of people would be very happy
about this kind of an award for good
music the National Endowment Chloe Erin
the Corporation for Public Broadcasting
David Stewart - fantastically imagined
at people and Zubin made and the Los
Angeles Philharmonic thank you very much
there's a lot of fun making it's a lot
of fun being here thank you